تحلق اسعار الذهب في سماء المعادن الثمينه
بمصر فقد صعد سعر المعدن النفيس عيار 21
وهو الاكثر شهره ومبيعا الى 1700 جنيه اي
ما يعادل 70 دولارا ويعزو تجار الذهب
باسباب هذا الارتفاع غير مسبوق الى زياده
قياسيه في الطلب تتزامل مع تراجع المخزون
المحلي وخلال 34 يوما فقط زادت الاسعار
بمقدار خمس مئه جنيه ما يعادل اكثر من 20
دولارا يقول الاتحاد العام للغرف التجاريه
ان مصر شهيده انخفاضا حادا في وتيره
استيراد الذهب كما يقبل المواطنون على
شرائه وسط مخاوف من التراجع الحاد في سعر
الصرف الجنيه الذي هو هذا العام باكثر من
25% وذلك منذ قرار البنك المركزي المصري
الصادر في اكتوبر الماضي والقاضي بتحريره
وتركه لعوامل العرض والطلب
حصولي على تمويل من صندوق النقد الدولي
حمى الشراء في اوساط المواطنين
والمستثمرين هذه الايام ليس هدفها شراء
المشغولات الذهبيه بالشراء السبائك لتحقيق
عائدات مرتفعه مستقبلا اما البنك المركزي
المصري فقد اشترى 44 طنا من الذهب في
فبراير الماضي ما جعله يصنف كواحد من اكبر
مشتري المعدن الاصفر بين البنوك المركزيه
العالميه خلال الربع الاول من العام
الجاري وتواجه مصر مشكله تفاقم معدل
التضخم الذي بلغ في اكتوبر الماضي 19%
مسجلا اعلى مستوياته في اربع سنوات
وذكرت وكالته فيتش لتصنيف الائتماني ان
احتياطيات البنك المركزي المصري لخطط الى
اقل من 32 مليار دولار في اكتوبر الماضي
مقابل 40 مليارا في فبراير من هذا العام
كما تتفاقم الدين الداخلي والخارجي لتجاوز
اربعه تسعه مليارات دولار ليصبح الاكبر في
المنطقه العربيه